I'm writing every Devil's fruit in one
piece to figure out which is the best
one this is the memo me which allows its
user to control and manipulate memories
it was eaten by putting the 35th
daughter of big mom this mesmerizing
fruit allows you to completely alter the
memories of anyone you touch so with a
single handshake any enemy can become an
ally and fight for you but it doesn't
really give you any extra strength so a
forgetful 10 out of 25 points here in
terms of Defense you can only make
people defend for you another 10 points
here however this food shines in terms
of special abilities with the power to
literally erase replace or create brand
new memories from scratch this fruit
earns a mind-blowing 22 points here and
it's of course super useful in everyday
life too since you can convince anyone
by changing the memory copy homework
anyone an enchanting 23 points here but
if someone tells your opponent that you
change their memories your powers are
basically meaningless so minus five
points here which brings the total to 60
points and not quite enough for the top
three or Goods